no I mean the stuff we talked about
today is stuff we never talk about I
never like human consciousness and and
the impracticality of aliens physically
visiting you know uh uh other planets
and you know solar systems and so on
within a Galaxy or other galaxies and
um so so much of the stuff today stuff
you know is never a great form to talk
about it's actually kind of fun stuff I
think about a lot or geek out on a lot
um so no that was the sort of stuff that
I would always be like more interested
in
having conversations these kind of
deeper more interesting things about
you know where are we what are we where
are we headed
um yeah that's more fun